so then that means you agree then that
Jesus wasn't created right it was at
this moment he knew no I don't agree
with that because the scriptures then
we're not
done Jesus being the first and the last
doesn't contradict him being the
beginning The Arc of God's creation I
never said it did you did that's
literally what you said no I didn't you
said being the first and the last means
you have a beginning and the end yes
that's what the words mean Jehovah so
Jehovah has a beginning when he says
he's the first and the last no that's
but you said if you're the first and the
last you have beginning and no I didn't
what did he say come on man what are you
doing a father can't be the first in the
last because he doesn't have a beginning
okay so you don't have a beginning if
you're the first and last right no I'm
[Music]
saying a father can't be the first and
the last because he doesn't have a
beginning so being the first and the
last me you have a beginning the father
[Music]
can't me just um yeah so I just saw your
open challenge doing the John Cena thing
I feel
it uh yeah I'm we've had conversations
before um I've had I've been on with you
and radar and a JP um packout session
but um uh yeah I'm not uh I'm a Believer
um I don't call myself a Christian
someone calls me a Christian I glorify
God because of it because first Peter
tells me to
um not a trinitarian you're Oneness
right no not at
all not one is not trinitarian not a
unarian I literally believe what the
Bible says about the Son and the father
and the Holy Spirit I believe in the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit I
just don't believe they're all the same
person as far as y'all say in the Nan
Creed that homo USI is that special
Essence because there's no definition
for it that's we don't we don't so we we
believe that there one there's one
Divine Essence three persons you don't
believe that right no so it's not I
don't believe that I don't believe the
definition of homo the or the loose
definition of homo us if you will do you
believe that Jesus is the father no's
son do you believe he's he's
created I believe he's uniquely
created so there were he came into
existence at a point in time right well
not a point in time in eternity passed
but there was a time where the father
was just by
himself right so then if there was a
time where the father was by himself
then there was no son then the son came
into existence that's not not eternity's
past that's a
beginning okay that's I don't I don't I
don't mind that because Jesus says he is
the beginning so I don't mind that yeah
but not not that he has a beginning he
is the beginning right but the father
didn't have a beginning he just always
was and is the the father is the
beginning as
well he's the first and he's the first
and the last right Jesus is the first
and the last that's what he says about
himself in Revelation what Okay so do
you believe you don't believe that Jesus
is
Jehovah no not Jehovah no okay so
Jehovah in Isaiah says that he's the
first and the
last yeah depending on what translation
you're read if you read that if you read
Isaiah 44 if you're reading the seilent
it literally says uh I'm the first and
I'm the Hereafter doesn't use the word
last right so he's the first he's the
last or the Hereafter but he's the first
so does that mean that the that you that
that's the father
speaking the uh yes speak it to Isaiah
yes okay so when the father is saying
that he's the first does that mean that
he has a
beginning no he just was exactly so
Jesus says that about himself he's the
first and the last the beginning and the
end right but that would be a
contradiction to what he says in
Revelations three where he says I am the
beginning of all creation of the
creation of God that's not that's not a
contradiction he's the source of God's
creation if you're saying the first is
the same definition Isaiah as it is in
Revelation 1 and Jesus is speaking
Revelation one and the father was
speaking in Isaiah 44 then Jesus
speaking in Revelation three for him to
say he's the beginning of the creation
of God will be a contradiction between
those two definitions of first in the
beginning if he started the creation of
God if he created if the creation of God
started with that meaning he originated
it with that with that um
phrase how can I say this will that um
can that phrase be applied to him that
he's the beginning of God's creation if
he started
it not being created himself but
starting God's creation could he be the
beginning of the creation of
God well yeah that's what the word would
imply it it would mean that definitely
right so so he doesn't have to be part
of creation to be the beginning of God's
creation because he's the source and
originator of God's creation because
it's he created it all so him being the
beginning of God's creation doesn't
necessitate that he himself is created I
wouldn't use the word Source there
because father ABA actually means source
and Jesus is not the father no the word
is RK there in Revelation 3:14 it's RK
which is Source or originator no so I'm
saying that the word for source and
Hebrew is Aba that means father no
brother we're not talking about Hebrew
we're talking about I know you're
speaking about the Greek but they have
tode with each other huh they the the
definitions for source and father they
have let just turn my mic all the way up
because I feel like yelling no I can
hear you oh you saying H and you want me
to repeat it so the def the definition
for
s the definition for Source right yeah
can't change the usage can change
depending on the word definitions don't
change let let me give you example like
a dog is a dog no matter what but if I'm
saying it's raining C C and dogs I'm
using the word differently but a dog
still means a dog I'm not saying a dog
is a cat or a dog rence I'm using the
word differently I I know the word
source is different from the word father
you
agree in English yes in Hebrew no in HEB
in it it is different in Hebrew ABA is
Source no ABA is Father yes that means
Source no it doesn't
and we're speaking of the Greek not the
Hebrew bro I know you were talking about
the Greek I'm saying that the Greek in
Hebrew would have to coincide they would
have to correlate if you're going to use
that for them them them but they don't
have to be the same word to correlate do
you
agree no but they have to be the I'm
just I was going sorry let me not cherry
pick anymore I was Cherry I was cherry
picking your your usage of the word
Source in not specific context so I
wouldn't say that Jesus is the source
because to in for me and how I my
interpretation of the Bible my context
and how the Bible reads in context Jesus
is not the father he's the son okay so
this is where um let's let's try to get
on the same page okay all right so
you're saying
that um for Jesus to be the first and
the last in the same way that Jehovah
claims to be the first and the last
which is exactly is you're saying that
that would contradict Revelation 3:14
where Jesus says that he is the
beginning of the creation of God right
you're saying when he claims to be the
beginning of the creation of God that he
himself is is the first thing God
created and it's creation started with
him in the in the sense that he's the
first thing that was created
and then everything else followed suit
right yes like uniquely created as if
like we're not we we a't we aren't
created in the same way that the father
created the son okay and so what I'm
saying is what I'm asking you is is that
um could Jesus be the beginning of the
creation of God by being in virtue of
being the source of
it meaning he's not the one that was
created but he created all of
creation could that yeah could that
definition or could that apply to him as
being the beginning of the creation of
God in the sense that he's the
originator of
it the originator yes but not the origin
like
so yeah they're not they don't mean the
same thing if you look it up
originator no yeah that is the same
thing if you are if you are if you are
if you are the origin
of your business you are the origin of
your
business starts with
you and start with go I'm rich I'm
talking I'm just I'm saying in the in
the I gave an analogy they say if you're
starting a business you're the
originator of your business and you are
the and you are the origin of your
business right okay right so originator
the definition means a person who create
a person or being in this sense who
creates or initiates something origin
is the starting point that the person or
being created that something from right
and so if you are the originator of
something you are also the origin of
that something would you agree not
necessarily
because no really in the word originator
originator come on man listen listen to
me if I am if I'm a software if I'm a
software developer right I'm the
originator but the origin is the
software in no you're no you're the
origin of that software it's not because
did the did the software exist before
you made
it yes it had to because I had to use
something to create
it it had to I'm not I'm not just
speaking code and then it's just popping
up out of thin a there has to be
something here for me to create the
software I have to program through
python or Java or react or node.js
if I don't have any of those I can't do
anything Apostle Jack what's up come on
man what what what are we doing here
man
dude I don't even know how to get how to
how to how to move forward I don't I
don't know how that's
complicated if I sit down if I sit down
and create app compated if I sit down
and create an app you did what you did
what you did what the app saying if I if
I sit down behind a computer and create
an app right an no yeah if I create the
application right so what's the origin
of the
app the origin is me
no hold on hold on hold on hold on go
back sorry
sorry my God come on man don't do that
the origin origin the origin is is the
program that I use you're trying to
you're trying to stay out that pot you
trying to hop out the pot don't flip
trying you trying to you trying to help
out this part don't do that the or you
creating originator is me means that you
are the origin of the app no the origin
is the code that I use the originator is
me I'm the author I'm where where the
code come
from whoever created the code who
created a person
okay so what's the origin of the code
the computer the person the computer say
that again the person a person the
person who creates the code is the
origin of the code correct it's the
originator of the code but you said it's
the origin no it's the origin you keep
you keep switching you keep switching
the words no you keep switching it no
I'm not I'm not I keep saying the same
thing the originator is a person the
origin is the origin is where that
something starts from oh is it yes okay
so if it starts with you are you the
origin
no okay so hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on chef chef Avery Chef
a chef logic my bad I don't want to use
your government name Chef logic because
that's on your hat right so so even so
look look look at me look crazy look
even if even if you believe like how how
look how trinitarians come off and say
that the son existed in the mind of God
right like before you were in your
mother's womb I knew the sun existed in
the mind of God before right there's
still a point in time where that
physical repes representation of the sun
wasn't existing he was in his mind does
that make sense no no that's not
existing number one God's forn knowledge
of you doesn't mean that you exist you
don't exist yet yeah that's that's what
I so the sun hold on so the sun here is
not just existing somewhere or or is is
as a thought in God's mind he was there
in the beginning with him from
eternity's past never came into
existence matter of fact he's called the
beginning the source of all creation it
starts matter of fact let me show you
this let me show you Revelation
3:14 let me just show you real this
really quick man and I saw I saw I saw
your
um your um by the way great debate your
debate with Captain tarya so thanks man
thank you kind of have an idea where you
might go all right where do you think
I'm GNA go I'm I'm going to Revelation
three still I'm still yeah I know but
you you're probably gonna flip it and do
that the thing where he couldn't Define
like like all of
creation yeah yeah I know where that's
going I'm not I'm not doing that but
that is a it's a good move to use I'll
tell you
that but no I'm not I'm not doing that
I'm just just um going over the the uh
going over the word AR here okay in
Greek right yeah in Greek okay so I have
it over here to the
right
um okay here it is AR okay
right click on
this look beginning origin ruler
Authority
principality right right yes so and then
we go to the Lexicon
because it gives you different stages
beginning or origin right used
absolutely of the beginning of all
things usages yes not the definition of
it well we we just we just saw the
definition was beginning in origin no no
notice it said origin and not origin
nature no no
problem all right so look um here's
another usage of it that by which
anything begins to be the origin or
active cause of a thing right all right
so and look at the verse that they quote
to support this usage right I don't
disagree with that you do because I I
don't disagree with it you do because
you're saying that Jesus is not the AC
of cause of God's creation he's part of
it he's not part of when it says that
he's beginning of God's creation it's
not saying that he's part of God's
creation it's saying that he is the
origin of it he's the act of cause of
God's creation he is that by which God's
creation begins to
be you just said the same thing like
that's exactly what John one says all
things were made
through a part of it okay good so that
means that he himself is not created but
that he has always existed and created
all things he's not part of creation but
begotten means uniquely created said no
it doesn't mean uniquely created it does
not does if you go to where it says
let's do
it my gosh I got manages right it does
not mean that John John 3:16 John 3:16
yeah let's go to it um I'm tripping also
Hebrews one if you want Hebrew one yeah
Hebrews one John 3:16 man
all right
monogan oops don't want to do that only
begotten only
begotten only begotten unique one and
only not uniquely created okay I think
created on there but it's Unique I'm
sing all right so with this being said
and yes Jesus is unique because he's the
only one who comes from who's begotten
of the father who comes forth from the
father's Essence that's what makes him
unique no one else does and and so then
that's the that's that's the caveat I
would have with the problem of the
trinitarian doctrine right it's this um
this word and I have a credible Source
from it's a guy named Roger E Olen wrote
this book The Story of Christianity in
my graduate
program um here we go it says after
wrangling and little agreement
Constantine himself proposed that the
new Creed the nine creed include the
affirmation that the son is homo usus
co-s substantial with the
father hold on what does that got to do
with what we're talking about I'm about
to go to it right now
Aryan sorry the Aryan Bishops of their
sympathizers pointed out that uh that
since the Greek word usia could mean an
individual um subsist subsistent thing
like a person saying the father and son
are homus could be interpreted as saying
they are are identical in every way
including being in uh including being
the very same person in two disguises
that would be modalism and
sanism the more common meaning of usia
however was substance or being so what
I'm saying is this word homo just like
you said Omni um uh what's the word he
couldn't say omnipotent
omnipotent um uh sorry no no no this to
that to that
d uh but just like you said United end
in the scripture omus also is it's a
word they added but that that the word
the the nature right because Paul in
scripture talks about there's only two
Natures there's spiritual and there's
earthy but you have to have this special
Essence the special nature what does
that have to do what does that have to
do being the source of creation let me
land because you just said that they
share this special Essence they share
the same substance the same essence yeah
the essence substance nature what is
this because it can't be defined in
Scripture that it was just described to
you
so yeah you you you just heard it say
that they share the same Divine
substance the same ontology same entity
that is God right right that was in so
what what does that how does that
address Jesus being the source of all
creation are we are we done with that no
no no yeah yeah I thought we had moved
on from that because you so so then that
means you agree then that Jesus wasn't
created right no I don't agree with that
because the scriptures then were're not
done that's not says you just you just
saw it that the word RK means the origin
or the act of cause of so it's not
saying that Jesus is part of creation
but it's saying that he's the act of
cause of God's creation right yes that's
what John one says and all things are
created I know so but you so so notice
this so Jesus being the first and the
last doesn't contradict him being the
beginning the AR of God's creation being
the active cause of God's creation right
I never said it
did Jesus is speaking in Revelation one
and the father is speaking in Isaiah 44
then Jesus speaking in Revelation three
for him to say he's the beginning of the
creation of God will be a contradiction
between those two definitions of first
in the beginning last because he can't
be the first and the last that means you
have a beginning the father just is he
doesn't have a beginning wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait a second
you said being the first and the last
means you have a beginning and the end
yes that's what the words mean Jehovah
so Jehovah has a beginning when he says
he's the first and the last no but you
just said if you're the first and the
last you have a beginning and it's no I
didn't I said if you're the first come
on man what are you doing you don't have
a beginning what are you hearing okay so
you don't have a beginning if you're the
first and last right no I'm saying the
father bro what are you talking about
look look no don't don't misrepresent me
bro do you have a beginning if you are
the first and the last yes or no the
father can't be the first and the last
because he doesn't have a beginning that
is exactly what I'll ask it again if you
are the first and the last I'm going to
repeat what do you have a beginning yes
or no the father can't be the first and
the last because he does not have a
beginning so being the first and the
last means you have a beginning the
father can't be the first thanks for com
in bot he went he went in straight bot
mode I man I I've only seen that type of
action with
Muslims I've only seen that type of
action with Muslims I have have you guys
ever I don't even know has a Muslim ever
done that has a Muslim ever said yes uh
no uh yes uh no I'm not saying that but
yes I am I never said that yes I did in
the same
second have you guys seen that in the
same second happened like
that that's what happens when you reject
the trinity
[Music]